If we look at just the US Chess Federation.
This is the rating distribution as of 2004.
Bear in mind that the first bin is about 200,
Whereas all the other bins are size 100.
If my rating is 1800,
then I am about 8110th place in the US,
But this is better than approximately 88%.
Therefore, another really important thing about the shape of distributions. And
what we're interested in throughout the rest of this course is the proportion of
data values, less than or greater than a certain value in the data set. So if I
tell you that my rating is 1800, you really don't know what that means until I
tell you the shape of the distribution of ratings. And you can see the
proportion less.